what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so normally our Green Lantern
videos come out on Sunday but I forgot
to record it so we're releasing it today
anyway this is black lantern Superman so
keep in mind these videos usually come
out on Sundays today's a special
exception but this is again part of the
events of blackest night now remember
blackest night happens over the course
of one night but it's like the whole
world's going to pot over the course of
a single night like everything's
beginning to go nuts now again the
purpose of these tie-ins is to answer
the question what were all the other
superheroes doing when these mysterious
Black Lantern rings just started
descending on the planet Earth now
remember this is all part of that whole
concept of the war of light the idea
that you have the Green Lantern's you
have the guardians of the universe you
have you know all these other Lantern
cores that are out there and there's
this prophecy called blackest night and
that all these different Lantern cores
will basically make their presence known
they will step out into the light the
semester core the Green Lantern Corps
the Indigo Corps the star sapphires the
black Lantern's they will all basically
step out into the light for everybody to
see them and they will end up engaging
in this massive war at the same time the
Black Lantern Corps will rise and
because of the fact that they will
basically kill everybody the emotional
spectrum will cease to exist everything
in the universe will die it's literally
in taunts it's the apocalypse in the DC
Universe is about as dark as it gets but
on the whole when blackest night first
kicked off all we knew is that there
were black lantern rings about putting
two and two together we can figure out
that because of the fact that the Black
Lantern rings were basically binding
themselves to superheroes who were
already dead the Black Lantern rings are
basically bringing the dead back to life
but as we went through that story what
we started to realize is that there's a
difference between animating a body and
animating a spirit and that for the most
part these are not tried and true
superheroes the way they were before yes
all their powers are still intact but at
the end of the day they're not
reanimated in a traditional sense
they're just corpses that are
essentially running around now what this
does is it ties into Black Lantern
Superman and it's one of the most
intriguing things about this the reason
being is because what we end up doing is
we end up picking up with post-crisis
Superman and Superboy now here's the one
you don't want to talk about here
because while this story is mostly just
fighting there's a lot of history here
and that's the really cool thing about
this so every video is someone's first
video we're gonna treat it that way in
DC Comics you've had you have
five seas and you have the multiverse
and that's it 1961 the multiverse was
invented 1985 crisis on Infinite Earths
killed it off 2006 Infinite Crisis
brought the multiverse back but it was
not the same as the original it was just
a little bit different Final Crisis made
the superheroes aware of it the whole t
verse and the crises summed up in ten
seconds that's basically what it is now
with regards to this black lantern
version of Superman this is earth to
Superman this is where things get a
little hairy this is basically 1930s
1940s Superman as he existed before 1956
and the reason why is because you know
with the flash of two worlds DC
introduced the multiverse right near
they said hey there's all these multiple
universes that exist out there and it
was designed for the purpose of
answering questions why it is that like
the original flash Jay Garrick had
vanished and was replaced by Barry Allen
with no real explanation people didn't
know where he came from people to know
what was going on DC said okay in 1961
here's the multiverse what really goes
on here is that ever since Barry Allen
was introduced in 1956 you have been
reading about a universe called earth
one we just never told you about it but
if you were reading comics back during
the 1940s you were reading a line of
comics called earth two we just didn't
tell you they switched anywhere along
the line now in truth DC just made it up
on the spot it was just a way to
reconcile these two things together but
this version of Superman this original
1930s Golden Age Superman from Action
Comics number one he existed in the
earth two line of comics for years and
years and years and years in 1985
because DC was getting rid of the
multiverse you couldn't have two
supermen running around one of whom was
from a universe that was not supposed to
exist after crisis on Infinite Earths
and so what they did is they took this
version of Superman and his wife Lois
Lane and they just assured him off to a
paradise dimension that was it it was
supposed to be heaven it was just
supposed to be crisis on Infinite Earths
ended they basically went to heaven and
that was it that was really all there
was to it
fast-forward to Infinite Crisis in 2005
2006 and what DC ended up doing is they
basically brought back this original
Golden Age Superman and his wife Lois
Lane now this goes into the whole
Infinite Crisis story you'll find that
down in the description we're not gonna
rehash Infinite Crisis if you want to
know about it watch the video but in
that event it was basically
superboy-prime one of the most popular
albeit one of the most polarizing
villains
in DC's history facing off against all
the superheroes and just wrecking them
handedly it really wasn't even a contest
for the most part but in that story this
earth to Golden Age Superman died he
officially was killed off and that's why
he's a Black Lantern is because he's
been dead ever since the events of
Infinite Crisis that's why he's back
here now he was given a proper burial by
the modern Superman you know by the
post-crisis Superman if we want to call
him that he was given an actual burial
he was you know buried next to the
Kent's different things like released
next to Jonathan and the result of that
he just kind of was you know remembered
that was essentially yetbut him popping
back up here as a black lantern puts us
in a precarious situation because
remember despite the fact that these are
not really the original superheroes
wearing Black Lantern rings they do have
all their powers and so this is
basically a black Lantern's Superman now
Golden Age Superman the way he existed
Becker in the 1930s and 1940s was pretty
weak in comparison to like his
post-crisis counterpart but as the years
progressed going into again crisis on
Infinite Earths his power became more
and more intense because it didn't make
any sense for DC to cross over earth one
and earth two if earth to Superman
couldn't keep up with earth once
Superman and so his powers began to grow
his powers began to expand within reason
he was always the weakest of the two but
when Infinite Crisis came around he was
powerful like he was I would argue as
powerful as post-crisis Superman so it's
not like the Black Lantern version of
the Superman
who couldn't fly and who was only so
strong this guy can do everything
Superman can do and that's what makes
him so dangerous but what this also does
is it brings him to the equation Conner
Kent now Connor Kent is one of those
characters that fans adore they
absolutely love him it is
it's crazy people love Conner Kent but
he is basically Superboy from the death
of Superman in the early 1990s DC was
trying to find a way to make Superman
more relevant because he'd been falling
out in popularity since the 1970s and so
because of that what they ended up doing
is they ended up killing him off well in
the time between Superman dying and
Superman returning we got a story called
a reign of the Superman and we got four
different versions of Superman we got
the Eradicator we got cyborg
we got steel and we got Superboy now the
problem was after Superman returned and
this kid who basically looked like Bret
Hart from the WWE nobody knew what to do
with him so what they ended up doing was
just kind of shuffling
and moving him around now he really hit
his stride when I believe it was Teen
Titans but regardless like that was when
he really seemed to like elevate to the
point of popularity because DC gave him
a purpose but his whole origin is tied
into the idea that following the death
of Superman
Lex Luthor had basically taken his own
genes modified them and combine them
with Superman genes to create this
character and that's really the legacy
that he's always lived with he's
basically a clone of Superman and Lex
Luthor combined into one now the reason
why this matters is because this is the
entire basis behind his stance in this
story and the reason for that is because
again you know with the idea of black
lantern Lois Lane chasing down Martha
Kent which isn't really that relevant
but it's a thing that happens we end up
being met with the arrival of
psycho-pirate now psycho-pirate is a
really really cool villain because
psycho pirates basically a guy who can
manipulate the emotions of others is to
basically say like you you're terrified
are you like aren't you so scared of
everything and then people will just
start freaking out they'll just start
losing their minds now it's not a power
inherent to psycho-pirate right like
it's not like he has telepathy or
telekinesis he uses what's called the
Medusa's mask and anybody who wields the
Medusa's mask can do what psycho power
can do he's a little more like impactful
because of his history you know we're
dealing with minds and different things
like that but anybody that wears
Medusa's mask can have the same effect
in this instance because of the fact
that Conner Kent has basically lived his
life as a clone of Superman and Lex
Luthor the manipulations of
psycho-pirate bring those emotions out
it basically amplifies the existing
feelings of Conner Kent with regards to
the fact that he feels like he will
never be as good as Superman and that is
HUGE because it's basically DC having
you know Conner Kent just pour out all
of his emotions to the world now for the
average reader people who are reading
comics at the time this was already an
existing concept it was already
something that people were for the most
part aware of in the sense that that was
the basis of his character struggling to
find a place as Superboy in a world
where everyone idolizes Superman so
because of that it is an interesting
scenario because remember the Black
Lantern Corps basically consumes the
hearts of individuals but only after
just pumping them full of emotion and so
in this instance you basically have
psycho-pirate manipulating the emotions
of every
and that's one of the reasons why I
would argue that when it comes to the
Black Lanterns and the purpose they
serve psycho pirates among the most
powerful because the purpose of the
Black Lantern is to charge individuals
with hate rage and with greed and with
all these different emotions so that
their hearts literally just begin to
fill up with emotional energy and when
that happens the black Lantern's kill
that person and consume their heart
which in turn charges the central power
battery of the Black Lantern Corps the
source of their energy so again it's
really really cool the way this unfolds
but what I want to do is I want to
sidetrack from this flight between you
know Connor Kent and Superman and
actually want to focus on Supergirl
now this is actually a really
interesting scenario and the reason why
is because this is actually Kara zor-el
Supergirl now a little more history here
when it comes to the character of
Supergirl there is the original
Supergirl Kara zor-el who appeared back
in the Silver Age of comics she was in
as a backup feature for Superman I think
it was for ten years and then she got
her own series and adventure comics but
the idea is that the original Kara
zor-el was basically another survivor of
Krypton and now of course her being one
of the most popular versions of the
Supergirl character probably the most
popular version of the Supergirl
character spanned for years and years
and years and years the problem with
this and one of the coolest things about
it was that the question always was
debated among fans who's stronger
Supergirl
or Superman well this question was
finally answered in crisis on Infinite
Earths but it was really more of like a
circumstantial situation it was the
anti-monitor trying to obliterate
everything in existence and where all
the superheroes went off against him and
almost all the superheroes fell Kara
zor-el was basically the last one
standing and so people looked at that
and said if she's the last one standing
and she's the only one that can really
hurt the anti-monitor
well then it stands to reason that she's
more powerful than Superman that was
basically the indication that was given
now of course the fact that she died
during crisis on Infinite Earths was
massive because DC was going back to the
status quo the idea was that Superman
was the last Son of Krypton and despite
how many fans
Supergirl had at the end of the day she
was not as popular as Superman and a DC
was going to use crisis on Infinite
Earths to go back to the status quo then
that meant every other version of a
Kryptonian anyone who was not Superman
had to die and that's what happened the
Superboy stories went back to retelling
the origin of Superman when he
younger Superman himself was the only
survivor of Krypton now because
Supergirl was so popular DC tried to
reinvent her and they basically created
a character named Linda Danvers who I
believe operated as like matrix or
something like that and it was this
weird cyborg thing from like another
dimension most people didn't like her
and so in 2001 DC came up with this
genius idea to basically create this
story where Linda Danvers met Kara
zor-el and it was cool because it was
basically this scenario where Linda
Danvers tried to save Kara zor-el during
crisis on Infinite Earths and it didn't
work
basically it sent in Linda Danvers into
this mental crisis or she just couldn't
handle her failure and essentially just
gave up this went into 2004 with a story
by Jeph Loeb called Supergirl many happy
returns and it was in the existing
Supergirl story but it was designed to
wrap it up it was issue 75 through 80
and so what they ended up doing was they
basically relaunched the Supergirl story
starring Kara zor-el and that's why
she's here the problem with this is that
DC had to find a way to reconcile her
original origin with the way that she's
here now and so what they ended up doing
is ended up going back to the drawing
board and saying okay so yeah are ghost
cities still there like she's still a
survivor of Krypton her father you know
zor-el was the one that saved her her
mother Elora was there along the way
little changes were made like her father
wasn't a scientist different things like
that but in order to rectify why it is
we've never heard of Argo city before
now DC said okay so along the lines the
villain Brainiac showed up and not only
to be bottled the Kryptonian city of
Kandor he took the city of Argo and
merged it with candor and put them in a
bottle and that's why we haven't seen
them yet because nobody knew it was
there and so because of that this
allowed her Azure out to basically
reunite with her parents now it doesn't
really matter anyway because her dad
ended up getting killed but her mom
remained in Kandor again it's the
inability to regrow those cities back to
their normal size that make them so
interesting but the reason this matters
is because with the death of her father
a Black Lantern ring crash lands inside
of Argo city / candor and when is it
happening here is her father reanimates
as a Black Lantern and so we basically
have two conflicts going on at the same
time there is post crisis Superman
facing off against classic Superman and
then there is a Supergirl facing off
against her dad and it creates some
pretty interesting moral quandaries
because what we end up having
here is this idea that not only did
supergirls father die he's basically
reanimated and they're faced with a
choice that he's gonna have to die again
this time at the hands of Kara herself
and so it's really really cool because
we also have this really cool moment
with like Martha Kent where she
basically is trying to fend off against
Black Lantern Lois Lane but it's also
the idea the Black Lantern Lois Lane
makes a statement of hey my ring is what
keeps me alive you can't kill me unless
you take my ring away is basically away
from Martha came to know what's going on
it's just kind of a plot device and so
what ends up happening is Krypto the dog
the Kryptonian dog actually you know
attacks Black Lantern Lois Lane
bites her hand off in when she's
separated from a ring gets totally
incinerated Black Lantern Lois Lane is
now gone out of the equation again but
jump me back over to Supergirl and Jemma
back over to the battle but you know
with her and Superman it's really
interesting to see this because it's her
basically facing off against her debt
that's really about it having to go
through and kill them also reconciles
with Superman himself facing off against
Black Lantern Superman now ultimately
he's defeated like he's basically taken
out by Conner Kent himself it really
kind of gives Conner Kent his moment in
the Sun in the sense that sure he is a
carbon copy of Superman but it doesn't
take away from how awesome he is
everybody's had that mantle they have to
live up to you right if it's like a
brother or sister like a dad or a mom
you know you're gonna be a doctor you're
gonna be a lawyer you know whatever the
case is they have to live up to what
they feel are impossible standards and
so again it hit a lot of people home
when it came to the character of Conner
Kent because they've all been down in
that position before now ultimately
again with the character of the super
girl's father he's is kind of locked out
you know in the sense that he's stripped
of his hand you know with his ring and
that's really it you know he's just kind
of stuck out there and there's really
nothing more to do he just kind of goes
back to the you know to being inanimate
they're the same thing with Earth to
Superman but again that's the purpose of
this is to basically say okay guys so
there are some characters who come back
as black Lantern's some of them die but
some of them don't and that's the
purpose this was basically a reboot for
DC in a lot of different ways it's a way
for DC to basically say okay so like
every superhero and every super villain
who's ever died is gonna come back to
life and then we're gonna figure out
what we're gonna do with them after that
we're basically gonna throw all the
pieces on the board we're gonna keep the
ones we want and we're gonna get rid of
the ones that we don't and that's what
brightest day does again it's pretty
cool it's pretty ingenious in terms of
how it's done but this is also
my favorite stories when it comes to
Superman so with that being said guys
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]